[Music]
[Applause]
i
gotta be me
welcome back to the break room everybody
i'm thrilled to be back and we're glad
all of you are here with us uh this is
of course the daily live show
broadcasting live from new rockstars los
angeles headquarters our actual break
room uh today we're of course talking
last night's
she-hulk episode um jessica's breakdown
just went up on the channel not too long
ago we're gonna have a little clip of
that we're gonna do a break room
breakdown on and we've got some other
great news dc stuff um
umbrella academy the boys
all kinds of fun and we're going to
write letters to emil blond letters to
blonsky letters
that's right oh yeah pony up all your
skeleton cowboys in the chat i see those
bony horses
uh
mistress of the she-hulk breakdown
jessica clemens
oh she's clapping hey
and then um
t michael bechtold
not guilty don't trust the media not
guilty keep it gussy to mussy
welcome everybody um yes oh and we have
a really fun redemption today so uh
shield head writer jessica gao uh did an
interview where she revealed that there
were a bunch of jokes they had to cut
from the series
specifically because they were too mean
towards oh
and um we have an inside source yeah
we've hinted at it before yeah um but
that inside source hooked us up with the
actual cut jokes yeah
these jokes were hidden away in a locked
vault in kevin feige's office but we got
a person on the inside and they they
broke in and they got us the jokes they
got us these jokes
for every 50 in super chat we raised
today we will read one of the cut
to too nasty for tv yeah too hot for tv
jokes
let's
let's give them one you want to prime
the pump a little bit yeah
i've been dying to read one of these
from my hushy to my to mussy
what how's everybody doing tonight
who's here on a date who's here on a
date you two together you two a couple
people say there's not enough sex in the
mcu hell
but they forget that dr strange got his
powers thanks to a bad hand job
got him they should have kept that in
that's not bad
broken claps in the chat for uh dr
strange
[ __ ] up against
we did very little work today we wrote a
lot of jokes wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait we didn't write this yeah
oh yeah these jokes are written by
you know what i'm actually going to take
these to the laugh factory tonight oh
okay okay
stolen jokes i'm the new carlos mencia
hey let's let's kick it off with some
headlines
headlines
um
first we got a uh
the actor
mohammed amir who's in black adam did an
interview where he revealed some details
about his role he said his his
character's name is kareem he's very
sweet loving and wants nothing to do
with anything i think
in the trailer there's the two
characters in the van that like black
adams kind of black out and catches the
missile that's heading towards the van
he is the gentleman in the van
and he went on to say he's the
centerpiece of it all with his sister my
sister is the hero of the movie i think
this isn't the sister the love interest
to black adam so that makes that i think
he's they're just protecting him mainly
mostly so is black adam gonna be
not the hero of the movie is he gonna be
he's never the hero or is there a more
villainous
villain
i think he's he's not a villain he i
guess he's the anti-hero what you would
call it because he's not bad but he's
not good he's he's just easy just yeah
yeah what's wrong with people
let's get some clear-cut heroes and
villains back in these movies not
everything has to be gray
not everything has to be ambiguous you
like old-school white hat black cats
stuff yeah i want someone to come in and
be like i am the good guy and then i
want the person to sit opposite at the
table for them to go i am the bad guy
and that's the end of the movie you like
a villain that says i am the bad guy
i'm the one who is the bad guy look at
me now i am the bad guy
my ship now um oh uh uh batgirl
directors adil and below uh
said in an interview they would make
another dc movie
yeah you don't want to be like
screw off giant movie conglomerate
would we say this is a droughty director
it's a desperate director yeah we'd love
to do another movie thank you for
wasting two years of our lives it is as
brandon
yeah i mean there are what five studios
in the world that can afford to make
especially really big budget superhero
type stuff you don't want to piss off
even one of them um
the actual quote was inshallah which is
uh arabic for in god's if god wills it
uh as they say we cross our fingers if
they call us we are there
yeah of course we hey they also yeah
they got paid to make money yeah by the
way those checks cleared already yes yes
so probably not as much as if it would
have been released right but they got
paid something yeah whoa noob master
almost getting us close to two jokes
okay well we might have to break them up
and thank you to um
uh new master mls beads a couple other
folks through some uh
beads
mls oh i thought something else um
what'd you think it was major major
league soccer beats
booty beats
booty beads
your microphone's
all right speaking of while we uh figure
that out we'll uh one more headline so
bad girl famously canceled famously
tossed in the garbage where all of our
audiences should have tweeted out those
things yeah they canceled her
but
right they can never for warner brothers
to get the tax break that they receive
by canceling background they can never
profit from it they can never sell it to
streaming this is not going to be a
zack snyder's justice league kind of
situation where years from now they will
release it they can never show this for
profit but they have supposedly been
doing what they call funeral screenings
around the warner brothers i'd choke
someone out or they're just letting but
people that worked on it they at least
get to see it before they set it on fire
i'd be so mad someone steal a copy of
this movie for us we'll pay top dollar
now i would never endorse pirating as a
proud member of sag-aftra i believe you
pay for every piece of media that you
watch
however
[Laughter]
we got an inside track at warner
brothers steal this movie for us let us
watch it maybe we'll add in the digital
effects yes maybe we'll we'll be an
effective yeah channel abby hoffman and
steal this movie because get her get us
into one of these screenings we'd also
go see it yeah hire us at the studio and
let us work yes janitors we could be
pages yeah um okay jessica you want to
read one of these i can do one do you
want to do this what are these banned
jokes kevin feige said this is too hot
for tv feige said too sexy for streaming
oh hey
hey
los angeles
how are we doing tonight is that your
mom is she single um you i got a joke
for you guys i got a joke for you guys
why didn't thor have a bris
why why because they couldn't cut
through his thor skin oh
can't be buried in a jewish cemetery so
sorry doris i'm sorry thor yeah uh
here's hey hey here's one for you stop
it tell me if you've heard this one
somebody's heard this one already uh
what's the only science that shuri can't
master
what's that
vaccines
what was that what was that for me
you didn't read the joke against
translate booty beans booty beads in the
chat guys
where are those sex spots that get in
the chat sometimes
the nights of our lives uh other other
headline uh umbrella academy renewed for
a fourth and final season and netflix
third one just dropped we uh enjoyed
that uh i've i really enjoyed it i've
enjoyed all the seasons of umbrella but
this last one was a ton of fun yeah
so that'd be cool and they get to they
know it will be their last one so they
get to finish the story and apparently
the creator of the show had said early
on that they had like four seasons in
mind so it seems like they've been
building to this they've stuck to their
plans a little bit yeah and i believe
they are now beyond the source material
oh okay they're beyond the comics the
the i think the end of season two was
the end of the comics so now
they're basically just winging it baby
oh we got a lot of peaches and uh
necklaces in the chat
and somebody put a peach and
[Music]
speaking of series heading into uh
season four uh the boys
uh on amazon officially added jeffrey
dean morgan to the cast for season 4.
they're going to just slowly start
bringing in everyone from supernatural
even like the coordinators was he on
supernatural he was the dad
everyone but the other brother
yeah i don't think they've announced
what role he's playing now and they
won't even see if he's like a hero or
not they teased that like i thought they
were saying maybe soldier boy's dad i
think he's gonna be or is that a joke i
think it's a joke but i'm not sure i i
hope he's playing tech night which is a
horrible superhero he's a monster and i
think he'd be perfect for it i i love
jeffrey dean morgan because in watchmen
we saw him as a horrible person he
deserves to be in the boys he should
have been the boys in season two maybe
he'll get to play jeffrey dean morgan
he'll play himself
out real actors like you know charlie
sterling kind of showing up in the first
episode how about this pitch maybe he
plays dean jeffrey morgan
uh we got a release dates for thor love
and thunder on the day it's going to go
digital which is actually not that far
off and so it's monday september 8th yes
and yeah so pinocchio's released okay oh
baby um there could be we're going to be
that's a really quick shout out we're
going to be covering all that stuff here
live on the break room all the disney
plus day and we've got a really special
kind of package we're putting together
for d23 that we're very excited about
more information on that to come but
know that we'll be covering that here
but so they released kind of the dates
for that along with that later in
september they're doing the dvd and the
blu-ray release and as part of uh some
of the deleted scenes we got
descriptions for some of the scenes that
are going to be the deleted scenes are
going to be included in the blu-ray and
the dvd brandon do you want to run
through real quick some of those that
have been announced oh yeah what they've
announced is like uh there's a scene
where they're looking for zeus where
it's thor valkyrie and korg they run
into a few characters while they're
seeking audience with zeus so probably
more of like what we saw in omnipotent
city
uh there's like a scene with star-lord
and mantis trying to convince thor to
help their cause there's a scene where
like a nonchalant thor chats with a
panic star-lord and mantis in the middle
of chaos an explosion thrust korg into
the scene uh and then finally there's a
scene where like zeus gives thor a
special tool after overhearing a
heartfelt conversation
would you think he gifted them this
thunderbolt that seems like very bizarre
right because or maybe he gives him
something that's like not actually very
helpful at all and then he still winds
up killing him to take the lightning
bolt
which would be funny but if it's just
like some grapes
if it's a fart machine
what if it's booty
um come on 30 more dollars i want to
read more of these jokes we worked
really hard on it i mean it is stealing
them it is fine
all of these deleted scenes though when
we want the like what we want is like
what did you shoot with lena headey what
it yeah that's the grand master stuff
you shot like that's what we want to see
well and it does make you wonder right
like again going back to the warner
brothers conversation
i think if they release like cut scenes
that it featured entirely cut characters
they then have to pay those actors
differently that's true so like we
probably won't see any peter dinklage we
won't see any lena heady um but there's
like an anchorman 2 here right where you
could all the stuff they cut they could
almost make the second hole yeah oh
four four a bigger longer uncut i like
what carlos is in the chat he gave him
the invitation to the orgy oh because
he's like you're not invited now he's
like here you go you deserve it you've
had a hard time that's a good one um uh
we want to shout out a couple super
chatters uh match143 saying let's get
these filthy jokes rolling baby
my nerd babies thank you match143 mls
beads uh again don't know what the mls
stands for i don't think there's not a b
in there so it can't be booty must love
sex beads
um mls means uh what do you think leaked
the video of abomination in wong at the
cage fight or who do you think leaked
that video also how did he get out if
there is so much security well right
yeah wong i think we know wong is
showing up in this series maybe that's
next episode he shows up to kind of
explain himself yeah to um
uh jessica character witness or jennifer
you're jessica that's jennifer
someone explained our names are very
similar uh well in in like could it be
how do you think just real quick
hypothetical
we see the emil blonsky we see has been
you know rehabilitated he's chill now
he's zen yeah he's thinking about his
future he feels bad about what what what
happened in the past do you think cage
fighting might have been a part of that
healing process oh getting out the
aggression oh yeah
yeah
sometimes it's it's in a structured
environment he's not fighting random
people or innocent civilians right
sometimes you gotta let the lion roar
you know what i mean what does that
sound like
are you insinuated that like he's gotten
out more than this one time or do you
think it was like a one-time thing and
the cage fighting fixed him that one
time no no no i think he was doing a lot
of case fighting
i i pitched in my breakdown that i was
like this could be our first time the
first time in public fighting um just
because there's only like it's like how
did this video just now get released if
they've been doing it over time or it
could have become the out the outcome of
what happened that night of the gold
daggers club getting like invaded by
everybody that people were like i'm
finally going to share this footage um
but it's so weird and i get into it in
the breakdown of like the timeline and
this is now just ever changing i don't
know where it is we don't know if it
yeah because we don't know if this just
happened yeah or if it happens oh and
now it comes out i think whoever leaked
it is probably no keep going keep going
you're about to say what i'm gonna say
and we'll get into it in the discussion
but like no thunderbolts yes stuff oh
because they want to keep him in prison
yes so that they have him there in
prison so they have leverage yeah okay
yeah we're
teasing a a later topic and if you have
some thoughts on blonsky throw those in
the chat we'll try to answer questions
later uh we appreciate all the super
chats uh but real quick we wanna thank
the folks that helped us bring this
episode this show to you all week long
our good friends at betterhelp are
helping us um bring this show to you we
want to thank them for sponsoring the
show hey keep in your mind and keeping
your mind happy and healthy is important
so why not invest some time money and
energy in doing just that um we have
multiple members of the staff here and
your rockstars have tried out better
help or are currently using it tommy
being one of them oh yeah baby this
prison is locked tight
laser a laser gate yes don't step across
the yellow line
it's not like she-hulk it's like uh uh
resident evil where uh yes everything
gets like absolutely
it's a child uh nightmare it's a
nightmare factory
uh
is that a professional diagnosis uh no
that was not i'm sure what your better
health therapist said no i'll tell you
exactly what she said oh no
tommy put that down
okay which we're gonna we're we're past
the next joke threshold we'll be getting
into that soon
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
therapy sessions
uh and because it's online you could do
it from anywhere you feel most
comfortable do it from here your car out
in the garage backyard you know hiding
from your roommate whatever you want
they even have the option to have the
camera turned off so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to plus it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy
and you never need to travel anywhere
our listeners can get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
break room that gives you a nice
discount it makes us look great with our
advertisers which helps us keep this
show going that's better h e l p
dot com slash break room it's better
help as in uh the octavia spencer movie
oh
the happy birthday yeah i know what you
mean yeah don't have to stare at me at
the face
do you know what that is jessica you're
familiar with that film
all right we got two jokes okay exactly
okay here i'll read uh i'll read a hot
one again can i go over the polls while
you guys get them right yes and again
these are um jokes that were cut for
being too steamy jessica wrote these
jokes uh do you guys think as they're
getting theirs do you think that black
adam has the potential to save the dc
you 59 percent of you said no i mean
that's a heavy game i need saving i
think it's doing just
fine okay yeah i think shazam is going
to take that spot yeah and then do you
plan on plan on buying love and thunder
on blu-ray dvd 90 or no said 81 percent
yes 18
uh who who buys blu-rays yeah who's
still doing physical media yeah i will
say if you want to tell me if you want
to do quality
video even those things are streamed 4k
there's so much compression still that
looks terrible also we can't trust these
they're
streaming
everything away they're still like
something like 80 of movies are not
available to stream
if there's a movie that you love i
implore you to buy it in a physical form
if you want to watch goonies once a week
for the rest of your life buy goonies on
blu-ray you know what i never regret it
on amazon those 200 episodes of sesame
street i bought physical media for yeah
now you're a guy you're saved okay you
know what i do regret
i think five seasons of king of the hill
on dvd without a dvd player yeah rest in
peace brittany murphy okay these are cut
jokes too hot for tv from she-hulk okay
this one oh this one is pretty rough
why did hoax family want him charged
with bestiality why why because he spent
18 months in gamma's lab
whose gamma
i don't want to know who gamma is i like
it
hey everybody who hears google's getting
it on daily nightly and oh so rightly oh
no you know your boy is you know your
boy is what does wong yell out during
intercourse what i don't want to do the
voice don't do the fortify your groin
yeah
but i did want to do it
too
fortify in your groin for my
[Music]
you guys don't have the balls to get up
upstairs we're releasing these we were
uncaging these jokes they would they
would otherwise never see the light of
day that's right um do we want to go
over the predictions first or the do you
want to do the discussion first
we the predictions might be a little bit
quicker
you think well where are you here we
already played
i'm sorry my sons are so upset
i need structure where is my calming
sand and today's recent new rockstars
breakdown i break down episode 2 of
she-hulk let's take a look at this
little clip really quick
emil mentioned he's been talking to
seven people within the prison pen pal
program and wants to run away with them
on their purchase property for him i
support this polygamy also i think we
see them in the she-hulk trailer you see
jen near milcell and behind her are
seven people standing wearing white tops
and i think crown so yeah i think that's
his seven partners i'm also like girls
you saw abomination you saw what he did
to harlem why are you over him like ah
going off about why people find
abomination attractive uh but he's got
he's got fins now
that makes you want him more yeah you're
insane also i when i rewrote incredible
hulk i was like too much of his bones
are sticking out protruding his skin an
incredible hulk he looks too much like
the human alien hybrid from alien uh
resurrection or whatever
it's like
the fins really balance it out okay i
like that they gave him more meat
in the trailer it adds some symmetry to
his face yeah i agree there you go uh i
usually just get bangs now so in the
captions they said soul mates but a lot
of people online are getting that mixed
up with cell mate because it does sound
like he says sell me but in fact he's
saying soul mates but some people have
been like maybe those soul mates are the
people they spent time in prison with
and maybe this could tie into the other
seven for the thunderbolts and what do
you guys think about that i like the
idea if it is these ladies right that
they're just representations for each
bad guy and he's using them as like a
front oh and like they're just like oh
yeah it's the seven women but he's
really communicating with like the seven
other members of the thunderbolts in
like a weird way i love that idea i love
that that he's playing jen he's playing
he's playing everyone like
everybody i mean i feel like that's
where this is heading right like he's
he's not genuine john costa gave 420 in
the chat grow up john john costa that
summer it's your it's your day off oh so
john when i donate i give ten dollars so
yeah
my boy philip needs to eat dinner okay
please give a little more money come on
can't just eat factory meals all day
i like that but uh yeah i like that too
well now real quick
who might the seven people be
that's the real question is it gonna be
people that are new or people that we've
already seen you know because he's
talking to the they're pinpointing
people it's obvious okay go sleepy happy
grumpy dopey doggy
doc
i think you're forgetting that it's
dasher dancer donna blitzen
um but we know us agents out there we
know elena beloved is out there yes aj
and emil blonsky are getting along just
fine once uh john walker hears oh you
win torah harlem you're my kind of guy
someone's gotta stop johnny mayonnaise
oh johnny man so it's nice that he gets
to have communication with the outside
world but i think it's also probably to
a degree since the dodc is like on
complete lockdown for him he can't even
like
jen can even cross a yellow line without
the alarms going are they letting him
get letters yeah how are they and also
they're scanning them and stuff you guys
yeah
what's going to do with that plenty of
people in my family spend a little time
behind bars yeah
you can get letters in there you can get
anything in as long as you you know hide
it put it in the cake that's what the
looney tunes
if we don't believe that our prison
system is there for rehabilitation what
are we doing we can't just lock him away
and throw away the key you should have
rights he should be allowed to talk to
him
he's a product of the gov government
malfeasance i did love his argument he's
got a great argument yeah he was just
following orders yeah he was lied to he
was misled by the us government and the
us military but that's why i agree i and
it sucks because of my breakdown i
definitely feel remorse but after
hearing everyone talk about it i was
like yeah he is being shady and he's
like playing us like a federal to agree
with tommy i just think that uh he for
he left out the fact that he held a man
at gunpoint to get the blood yeah but at
that point he was under the influence
and had been nearly killed no i think he
was just but i think it was he still it
was in control of his own mind i think
he was just angry and his anger with the
soldiers yeah is really bad probably to
like the 10th degree but i think it's
also like you're still control of what
you're doing he also grew up in a time
of leaded gasoline okay and it destroyed
a lot of young men's minds that's true
and who knows what kind of paint we're
on the walls of his nursery
he's sitting there using lead-based
chips and if you had a cat in the house
he could have talked about russian born
british raised you know he wasn't
getting proper hygiene we don't know how
how close he grew up to chernobyl yeah
you know oh my god you guys are
ridiculous so do we think um going back
to who we think will be on the
thunderbolts we're clearly setting them
up with the other people that we already
saw but if he's talking to pen pals his
pinball is not yelena it's not going to
be johnny mayonnaise
how else would he be able to talk to
them though i think it was okay so i
think he was because remember in shield
how they were like oh he's in cryostasis
or whatever maybe he was moved from
shield this is after cryo maybe he was
in shield talking to other people before
he was moved to what we see now is the
dodc super max prison so maybe in that
little uh transfer he made friends with
people they get to come keep in contact
with i also kind of kind of think that
it's the people that we saw in the group
therapy session online like with
porcupine and man bull and all of them i
think those are his pen pals
oh interesting and they're kind of like
his soul mates well i do like like so
many yep there's that image from the
trailer we have yet to see this so far
um hopefully maybe next episode yeah um
thank you dazzle i i do
yeah soulmates is such an interesting
term right because it's usually as a
romantic connotation but it could if
you're if you're super zen and you're
like i just want to connect my soul to
as many people as possible maybe it's
not a romantic and it's just kind of
like a very you know
kind of culty thing yeah that's why i
think well the the people in seven or
the seven white tops and crowns around
their head i was like okay we're playing
at this from a different angle what what
would the abomination cult be called and
what would the cult members be uh it
would be called it would be abomination
emile blonsky is a non-denomination
abomination
jamboree
and they're bombings or what are they uh
yes a bombs hey bombs
i like that they're nasty nations
do we think that um i kind of want to go
back to were what brandon was kind of
saying earlier too about if he is like
orchestrating all of these things in the
prison is
do you think val's falling for it well
but val could be part of it like if val
is operating in kind of a shadowy way
outside of the purview of the dodc or
something and this is her only way to
get through to a meal
uh securely is through this like this
way i think i could see how she's still
facilitating that she's like she wants
to usher the seven pen pal or the yeah
communicating to get on the same team to
like formulate a plan together to get to
know each other get it along because
that has been the downfall of the
thunderbolts in the past is that because
they're all kind of villainous they
don't trust each other and they a lot of
infighting or they're led by a maniac
who has multiple personalities
a lot of problems uh exist what if
they're set up like a basketball team
and they got two they have two sets you
know like they're like oh these are the
first ones and then we're going to like
yeah hockey the first line in the second
life yeah i also love uh max savage in
the chat which what a name max savage
nice screaming he's a savage
classy bougie ratchet
remember that two years ago what a great
hat a great super chat uh is it public
knowledge that the flag smashers were
hopped up on the serum and if so
maybe jen uses that as an argument in
court there's no way it's public
knowledge i bet they kept that under
wraps johnny danny's takes it you don't
think he's going to tell everyone no no
he take we all know he took he was on
good morning america and they're like we
gave this boy super juice they i i'm
sure the government wants to keep oh
keep quiet the fact that there was like
rogue juice floating around yeah i think
yeah other people start looking for it
or maybe
doing it um mls beads uh was real
popular this episode wants to know what
your seven uh cult like followers would
be called tommy oh
uh
well i would think my seven let's think
about this let's think about the brand
i think they would be called uh
monday tuesday wednesday thursday friday
saturday sunday and each one would have
to do a specific day where they do
whatever i want and they make me
breakfast and it has different kinds of
breakfast meats sometimes sausages
sometimes sometimes bacon and then they
put on my favorite movies and they keep
the air conditioning below 70 degrees in
the house at all times
that's
food i just don't want to keep watching
the same movie over and over again
tommy's mommies yes
[Music]
you guys
how is chicago doing wendy oh we're
doing great we got it the socks are
doing uh terrible this year okay that
was enough
guys what does iron man suit in an
ambulance have in common whoa
there's usually a dead guy inside
too high thank you thank you there it is
thank you for tv
uh jessica said kevin feige said
absolutely not
oh man so deep so deep i put her butt to
sleep speaking of sleep
i want to talk about
helix sleep baby it's important to get a
good night today is a good day to do it
here actually yeah yeah the lakers beat
the supersonics rip seattle supersonics
it's important to get a good night's
sleep and nothing helps you achieve the
perfect night's sleep like the right
mattress yeah that's why we want to
thank our friends at helix sleep helix
sleep has a quiz that takes just two
minutes to complete matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else again i have to clarify if
you have children
you should buy them a mattress that is
the one time
where you should do that or maybe your
gift giving and you really want to know
i buy all my ladies mattresses they
gotta earn that what about all your
tommy mommies all my tommy's mommies
have helix mattresses now
everybody's unique and helix knows that
so they have several different
mattresses models to choose from they
have soft medium and firm meshes i like
it so soft that i sink all the way to
the bottom of it grotesque and my butt
hits the floor yeah listen
it's great for cooling you down if you
sleep hot you know me i like to have
about a baker's dozen people watching me
sleep just to make sure that i don't
snort too loud
thirteen yeah you're like a french king
going to sleep i want to make sure i
don't get poisoned in the middle of the
night mattresses that are great for
spinal alignment also they prevent
morning aches and pains and even a helix
plus mattress for plus size sleepers
like me give me the plus helix i love my
helix mattress i sleep on it every night
sometimes i even i lie and leave houses
and say i gotta go i got a doctor's
appointment in the morning that's not
true
i just want to sleep on my helix
mattress you said that to me last night
well zach you know what you didn't want
to have a cuddle party you don't want to
make a puppy pile i'm out so take the
quiz and order the mattress you're
matched here the mattress comes right to
your door ship for free you don't ever
need to go to the mattress store again
and thank god because those guys let's
be honest they're pill takers
just go to helixsleep.com
break room you gotta i mean you gotta
fortify your mind to work in a mattress
store no offense mattresses in the chat
take the two minutes
and they'll match you to a custom
mattress that'll give you the best sleep
in your life they have a 10-year
warranty as i said before that's two
summer games two olympic games and then
another
game of your choosing that's a total of
five olympics and helix is offering up
to 200 off all mattress orders and two
free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
breakroom use that code help us help you
i want you to sleep well i want you to
earn that sleep on a helix mattress so
use our code slash break room baby thank
you thomas um i also just realized that
we never did the predictions we'll do it
at the end of this episode oh okay thank
you uh if we get to if we if we we gotta
talk about andor uh
i do have andorra again sorry my bad i
should have never assumed
yes it's mandatory fun this segment so
popular that we
what was that did you hear him he went
over here he does a good jetson sound
can we do it again brandon
no
stage fright yes oh don't put him on the
spot that's fine play my graphic again
yeah
mandatory fun is rated nc seventeen oh
for one scene of sensuality and harm
towards animals wait wait wait wait wait
wait hold on huh no i can't do that
they're different scenes
you mentioned gamma's lamp
hey listen spend a little time in
gamma's lab you'll get what all the
hype's all about okay
listen to me
focus
first of all both of us by the time that
this segment
is over
i want to see 42 more dollars in that
super chat oh my god i'm never doing
mandatory fun
wow
come on can't do that i will take away
mandatory i'll take the keys away kids
literally turn this car around we're not
going to disneyland today okay you
little bastards whoa wow give generously
it's thursday at disneyland payday
right classically thursday is the payday
i didn't get paid today it's friday i
haven't been paid in years
anyway amir blonsky offered a more
sensitive side on this week's episode of
she-hulk do we believe him i don't but
namaste
one thing he revealed is that he had pen
pals in the system his soul mates we've
covered this so
for today's mandatory fun i've asked us
all to write letters to a mill
i'll go first you know since i asked you
that's generous of you
this is the letter you wrote this is the
other one i wrote you a meal blog i love
this in your pocket it's warm yeah so
that's it so now you got it back or is
this a copy of when i say i do
facsimiles of all
a little drama and these are all cut
jokes too dirty to work their way she
ejected these jokes from she-hulk okay
what's the sound of one hand clapping in
the mcu
the agents of shield all screaming
i don't know if i get that one
because
i mean we don't know because we didn't
write these jokes that was this is the
writing team on on uh she-hulk
presumably that's because um that agents
of shield has was really bad from the
mcu it's like their their voices are
excited to find one that's offensive
okay you know they didn't all get
canceled because they were offensive all
right
who likes to get nasty
i guess i do how many people here like
to get nasty
wow
i was dating this girl who was such a
freak oh yeah how much of a request
she was institutionalized
why did hulk's girlfriend turn evil
why
too much green goblin
that was funny that was a good one
okay wait a minute who wrote this
jessica
jessica
jessica
thank you
we got it we got an extra one there
because one of those was the stinker you
know what they can't be winners they
can't all be ready
i just need to think about i think it
was a thinker i think you're not the
thinker do you think
we're going to look back on this day and
think this was a special episode john
put a freaking tomato in the chat john
i'll come to your house and shove a
tomato down your beautiful throat
zombies mommies get ready for the booty
tommy's mommies let me hear you in the
chat
dear emil
i hope this letter finds you well
i've been working hard on that project
you asked me to help out with i'm not
sure how many more supplies i can hide
in my jail wallet
yeah
look it up
i'm starting to feel ill with a box of
scraps jammed up my ass
after regions yours in christ team
christ
i like it
thank you
i have mine i can read mine mine was
actually sent back to me oh
yours was a return to send because i
really didn't like it but i thought it
was good uh dear meal hi i just wanted
to say i think it's kind of shitty how
you've been locked up for shared
destruction of the city i don't normally
do this but i'd be interested to see in
what you can give me i'm moving too fast
what i uh what i mean is when i saw you
on channel 6 flipping cars i thought if
i thought what if i was one of those
cars you remind me of my dad what's your
sign i bet you're a gemini i'm a tourist
okay this is kind of all over the place
i'm really just trying to shoot my shot
like you i don't handle losing well i
think we actually have a lot in common
we both have been [ __ ] by the
government a whole ton of packing taxes
and i assume you do at this point too
okay it keeps going
okay so well government please just let
me off uh okay so what i'm thinking is
once you're out we can move into my
mom's condo in fresno it's not the best
but it's a starter home also what's your
body count in murdering and in people
should i be concerned about either of
them i haven't killed someone so i feel
like i'm already the bring home the mom
type either way i think you're hot with
your gill-like head and sharp teeth
maybe you can crush my pelvis whatever
works you know see ya
wow you covered a lot of ground in that
letter
i was just gonna say so that sounded a
lot like uh stan by eminem oh that might
not be the last reference to stan
i guess i'll go ahead here um
now i am you know yours on actual letter
yes and you know what brevity is the
solo wit and i've got no wit in my soul
so um
i'll just skip around dearest and mill i
did want to keep it kind of intimate uh
first off thank you for your service my
mother recently retired from the va and
my father-in-law served in vietnam so i
feel like we're basically on the same
level
as far as service to country um
i'll just i'll skip to
uh with all that said i agree with your
views on israel and
we don't know what they are
we don't know
why i don't i don't want to go back and
read all the
israel and i think we should be together
like eminem and stan
ps loved you and reservoir dogs pps i've
included some nudes and a picture of the
large
piece of property i bought for us yes
beautiful okay i did not i will not show
those on sounds gorgeous
well you guys don't know this about me
but actually i've served a little time
oh wow i've actually served time with
the meal oh wow so this is a letter i'm
writing back you like handed this to him
well i'm gonna send this i've said that
yeah oh okay but i'm gonna send it to
him now that i'm out and i'm free
a meal
i can't believe how fast the mcu moves
on the outside i saw a suit a person
injected with super soldier serum once
when i was a kid but now they're
everywhere
uh
the mcu went and got itself in a big
damn hurry
happy hogan got me into this halfway
house called the brewer and a job
bagging groceries at the circle put it
in the chat if you know what he's doing
here this is my letter to what are you
talking about bathroom break boss
it's hard work and i try to keep up but
this chick with big hands keeps showing
up and wrecking things
i keep thinking justin hammer will show
back up and say hello but he never does
oh man i hope wherever he is he's still
dancing and using spray self tanner
maybe i should get me a quinn jet and
blow up the circle cube so they send me
home i want to go back to jail
i can even shoot bruno while i'm at it
sort of like a bonus
oh my god i guess i'm too old for that
kind of nonsense anymore i don't like it
here i've decided to go to dc i doubt
they'll kick up any fuss not for an old
crook like me
p.s why won't rody ever be a politician
because he can't run for office oh
he's snuck in a joke and you have to do
another one it was written in there wow
that was uh brandon brooks barrack here
uh he's got another one he's got another
get it set
i don't like that one
we should have really vetted these who
should have had these jessica gao
okay this is from jessica rejected by
kevin feige for being too mean uh what's
the only thing in the mcu that can stop
black widow oh god what's that a bullet
the ground
wow savage wow savage max max savage
really quick for me daschle yeah let's
run through our predictions so last
night a lot of things happened and this
is where our score left us zach with ten
tommy was five
that's not true well let's go through
what the prediction is okay so the first
one was
will there be a team up yes and i think
i got that right a she-hulk team up with
somebody i said no
that was correct i said no which i think
is correct and i said yes because i
think hulk i i think she also you said
that she would teamed up with nicki to
furnish their new office they didn't
furnish it yes they did they had the
mini frame followed by put it in there
he said that that that they would team
up with nikki and they also teamed up to
show everybody a great time in the bar i
think i think she did team up with i
think
us all wrong and him right no i think
we're technically still oh we can all
get them i think everyone who's the
ultimate uh decider of this do we give
it to the chat okay all right chat vote
on it but i'm right
did that count as a team up the other
one was how many times well uh she hulk
out she hulk she holds she hulk out uh
and we had said 3.5 yeah i took the over
i took the under he took time to take
behind her i think i took over i think
we were the same and it was three
so it was only a good point for that
nice uh the under and then the other one
was what it was make a prediction about
emil blonsky
i said
i said that he was going to dance
and i think that verbally
no absolutely not he did not he didn't
dance he didn't dance i do want my
points for this how many times when did
she hulk out
she hulked out when she got or no well
the bar and she hulked out when she got
in the building
then shut the law office
out
when she left
that's it yeah that's three yeah that's
three yeah i i wish we had like a
play-by-play of when these things happen
because i'm like i don't freaking
remember we'll write down the time codes
next yes okay so if we give tommy those
five points and that leaves time can you
bring that scoreboard back up
that leaves tommy with ten
trash bags with i don't know how much
you guys get for choosing me
what do what what is it you got five
points uh last night so the trash bags
they chose you so they also got five
points these are totals oh these are
total passes for the season come on
this pole is neck and neck we can do
this
let's get some yeses in there for all
the comedic gifts i've given you all
these years i'll fight brandon for his
score but i want to fight tommy for his
uh tommy come on
again we'll be doing this for every
episode this season of she-hulk uh
there's a lot of scoring left to happen
so who knows
bachelor weekend a lot of scoring and
then we'll get another pull-up about who
you guys want to vote for for next
week's poll yeah we'll do our next
week's predictions on wednesday
and don't forget the stakes are high
literally could be a steak dinner
wall of champions photo on the wall of
champions and the loser i believe will
be uh publicly beaten
that is the only reason you guys i fight
everyone on this table if tommy did not
say we get to choose any expensive meal
we want i wouldn't be fighting you guys
i don't have food at my house
koi's points are uh
fragrant koi's points are in a very
special lock box that we keep uh next to
jokes yeah next to the jokes from
jessica gal uh no we have everybody's
scores we'll we'll play those but we
like to do the scores of the people that
are on the show presently but rest
assured coy will get all his points and
it's official folks it's a team up
tommy
his appeal worked uh we want to shout
out a couple super chatters real quick
thank you to everybody who's been
chatting super chatting with us all
episode jackson rump which i thought max
savage was a great name and max
clarified max savage is his legal name
awesome name
jackson rump
if that's your legal name that is a
pretty great i don't believe that's max
savage's legal name if it is please tell
me your social and your mother's uh get
out of here get out of here uh jackson
rep just saying love you guys we love
you too jackson i went to school with a
guy named spartacus oh okay
i'm spartacus you're not i'm spartacus
no you're not gonna kill me you know a
guy named sky king yeah that's a great
name if you hey if you've got a great
name throw it in the chat yeah um jesse
you know someone with a great oh the
mj2997 coming through with a big old
joke uh donaish um thank you we will
give you a couple there uh vagabonda
light thank you we cannot lose mandatory
fun agreed
um
uh new master of course tony kevin
popping in for a quick super chat
kevin's a great name two first
washingtonians represent wow absolutely
tony what's it tony young big fans this
year seatac airport
wonderful place to fly into town
it's a mess it's always under
contraction it's always under
construction they always move my flights
my bucky barnes atl thank you keep it
gucci damucci always
meniks
men iix uh
i thought i i thought i missed it hell
no dog you're always on time ready okay
we've got our next penis
and you guys always come at me so i just
gave you the honest truth
lines
okay this is like this is a good one
this is the title
roadie looks like sam wilson if you drew
him from memory
i love it hey it got cut from the
episode
this one's more of just like uh like a
uh original kings of comedy not original
oh you on the king's accommodation no
the uh
the rednecks of comedy right oh yeah
i love this one so i'm gonna do this in
my best uh jeff foxworthy voice
professor x doesn't mind trying to help
wanda but even he admits that sometimes
she can be a pain in the neck all right
hey
um what's up tacoma washington i got a
joke for you at the laugh factory uh why
is that hard to understand want a
maximoff's opinion why she's not a
parent oh
do you think jennifer walters presumably
she-hulk will go with val or regular
avengers i think you know i think this
time helping uh the legally aggrieved
might put her on the side of of like the
thunderbolts yeah she might not want to
trust any like real government agency or
something now would she go with the
shadow organization i don't know but uh
i i could see her being like no the in
my opinion it's the jedi who are bad
well and and she could go along with
them until
you know they turned bad a little bit
and then there's a fissure in the
thunderbolts and she's kind of on the
good side and has to fight off
characters like abomination full better
call i'll be like nah these people need
help too and let's make things fun did
you have your job oh you already said it
no
brian k sent in a super chat thanks for
all the entertainment
thank you for for being here for that
entertainment brian k it's our absolute
pleasure and this is me just sending in
uh a super chat no no message
attached to it new master throwing out a
couple more doubloons do you think val
knows who daredevil really is oh i
wouldn't be surprised
but it's like how many people know from
the series how many people never know we
still
do do we 100 know if this is like
netflix daredevil not really if because
that netflix daredevil kingpin sussed
out it was matt murdock
if kingpin still knows that i don't know
in this um
at the end of the third uh if you were
to say this let me know at the end of
the third season the last episode he's
like hey as like
as long as you don't um
tell anyone about me i won't tell you
like as long as you're gonna know that
mike's not on right no but he can point
himself
when i was just gonna say the mcu has
made a conscious choice to not have
secret identities yeah right like there
are a lot of characters yeah well i mean
really what yeah
i mean spider-man is different and that
also is i mean like hot guy's got like a
hidden family sure but he's not hidden
that's like he's not hitting right right
people know clint burton is right it's
not no one knows who spiderman is and
that's like a big deal and
one more time is that the wilhelm scream
oh my god
i don't remember that being in the
woolsey in school
oh there's a couple jokes that that need
yeah uh what can be a black widow the
ground could have used your will
um
uh we do have a few minutes left
oh and we could talk about andor for a
couple of minutes okay because i love
the door
i want to give it a full minute uh uh
you want to give it a full minute here's
your full minute on android okay so uh
they did a tony gilroy the creator of
the show he gave an interview that was
really great in variety and i recommend
you read it it doesn't really say a lot
what the show is about subject-wise but
it does get into the tone of the show
where basically you know they approached
tony uh after he had worked on rogue one
and they were like do you want to do
uh a show and he was like no thank you
uh and then they kind of sent him what
they were working on because he didn't
want to do a story of leading up to
rogue one because he's like you see what
happens that's the end blah blah blah uh
and they kind of approached him and
they're like here's what we're working
on for this like cassian andor show he
saw that and he was he responded with
like a long document that's like here's
why you're wrong basically and laid out
like what he sees the problems are and
they're like okay well you want to do
what you said and he was like yes and so
this show is going to be very different
from all the star wars shows we've
already said he you know the title of
the article was basically this is not
like a kids this is the first tv show
star wars tv series that's not for kids
and he was saying like i don't want i
don't think a nine-year-old would watch
this show or enjoy the show it's not for
them oh uh and this show is about he
really described it an interesting way
where he's saying this is this show is
about the people of star wars where all
the movies are about royalty they're
about the sky jedi are they saying it's
not for kids because it's going to be
like heavy and dialed in
it's going to be about like factory
workers and politicians and they had
like 200 actors on this show uh playing
all these different roles in different
parts and it's kind of about like the
rebellion building up and all the little
stories that they can tell uh with the
building up of these characters uh and
yeah it's gonna be uh he describes it as
like a thriller uh i'm super hyped for
the show they also didn't shoot it on
the volume where they shoot a lot of
their stars it was like more on
locations yeah yeah they built these
huge sets and they talk about this big
city you see like they they built this
like big city and i think the volume is
incredible and they do great stuff on
there but you know it works well for
some scenes for some it feels like why
are they so close to each other in this
huge desert uh please stay off tatooine
on android please don't ever go to
tattooing on the show i'm begging you
please don't uh but i'm super excited to
see the show and i think it's gonna be a
lot of fun i will hype it up any chance
i get absolutely because i i like what
they're doing and i like that this show
is going to be different than the others
and if there's a little kid that shows
up in the first episode they have to
report a baby version or a baby version
or something i will bring up sandy
chewbacca you gotta bring a baby
something that's how you make the money
yeah
what would a baby chewbacca sound like
brandon he'd be like
[Music]
i can show you what a baby r2d2 sounds
about hey hey hey you hear this one guys
you hear this one
i hear my sources are telling me black
bolt was holding out for more money to
join the illuminati why did you hear
that you hear that yeah but in the end
he caved
hey
family shout out uh 666 manuel manuel
maybe uh sandy's turning 28 today
rise up confirmed trash bag i love you
guys we love you 666 manuel um
you know what i got one in honor of you
uh here's a freebie you know i was going
to make a joke about peter parker but i
forgot it oh
god damn hey goddamn
is it the cat hey
hey everybody it's so good to see you
some of you heard this one already yeah
why doesn't groot the famous shocking
tree big big guy we all know who he is
why doesn't groot
watch romantic comedies why why doesn't
group enjoy a romantic comedy why
he thinks they're too sappy
you're getting this one kevin's buggies
are too risque
you hear this one you hear this one you
hear this one you hear this one
how much
does it cost to kill tony stark's family
how much one buck
that's a good one my god
hey i got one he's hitting his own
soundboard ladies
get them ready get them ready get them
ready uh i got one i got one for you at
ucb franklin
why was reed richards late for hizu mean
why was he late for his zoo meeting
y'all why
he was being pulled in a bunch of
different directions
i think uh
new new master just threw in the chat
can you tell us your favorite naughty
word
um oh i mean booty bees
cinephile
i really like the the the uh the sound
and structure of penis wrinkle yeah oh
i don't know if that counts as a dirty
word shut up get out of this get out of
here
i think
uh bag of dicks oh it's pretty nice
pretty fun i mean i love i love an mf i
love a gd yeah i love a gd when you
spill it with a t yeah
damn
kind of nice yeah hey did you hear the
one about clint barton yeah
neither did he
okay last one then we gotta go
oh i got one i got one no let's do two
more because i want brand new one more
hawkeye i get it now i get enough
hawkeye and black widow deny ever
hooking up but he definitely had a fling
with her an end game
she died
off the cliff where is it going it's
going off it's out of here what's
unpredictable green and terrifying what
gamora splattered at the bottom of a
cliff oh my god give me one more brandon
give me one more brandon
i knew the wilhelm scream this one's
more of a reader than a hero but good
luck good luck uh which guardian of the
galaxy gets horniest from holding a book
what's that that'll be red rocket please
don't move but red is do it r-e-a-a-d do
it
all right i go in here what's the secret
sex club aboard the sword space station
called what
skrull and bones i would go do it you
guys what do roadies legs and maria hill
have in common
what what both stopped working after
captain america
oh
okay
why does floor struggle with eddy
because only those who are worthy can
lift thor's hammer
thor's hammer is his penis in this case
yeah yeah
yeah who wrote these
hey guys jessica what does the 69 and
new master 69 stand for well i don't
know why uh when two people give each
other some simultaneous oral sex that's
that's more of a face that's not really
a joke
okay what's that
tommy todd
thank you all so much for joining us
i've been away from the show for a while
and it was great to be back
with you guys
welcome back
uh thank you all for joining us we'll be
back of course tomorrow we've got some
fun stuff and then all next week
and it's that that first week in
september that's disney plus day it's
going to be 2023
a lot of really cool stuff in the short
term coming up for us here on the break
room and new rock stars in general watch
jessica's she-hulk episode 2 breakdown
if you haven't seen it hey if you
haven't seen eric's
house of the dragon episode one
breakdown it's awesome it's out on the
channel already um check out the tic tac
we're on tick tock
underscore break room uh check out our
discord where you can submit voicemails
you need to make clip of the week we
should have two this week because we
skipped last week so tune in tomorrow i
have two clips of two weeks maybe uh two
two click tomorrow two clips to to
handle uh yeah join the discord uh keep
watching we'll be back here tomorrow for
our friday show always fun it's really
richard and every other one do it dude
r-r-e-a-d yeah
let us